Get ready, you stray cows It's not the time to
think about it Now, I have to do something about
them The captain and the other guys won't be coming back for a while, so the
three of us will do the second set me wh
Anyway, a bluff ar
2 clip is amazing
The white coat is
still bad, and the bad guy who hurt me
only made our hideout, the
doujin tank man, I'm indebted
[music]
You can use it for the storage department.
-
I'm filled with my gel
le Punch Now I'm a dj dj I've
changed my yellow makeup
er
Ahhh, if it's cherry blossoms, it can be dark The
mirror is so big, it's
Lee Joon I can't imagine
holding something like that because of magic  It's pretty interesting